supposing we hit the body with a  tremendous whether it's ultraviolet or  just very powerful light and I think you  said that hasn't been checked but you're  gonna test it and then I said supposing  you brought the light inside the body  you can which you can do either through  the skin or in some of the way and I  think you said you're gonna test that  too  sounds interesting right and then I see  the disinfectant where it knocks it out  in a minute one minute and is there way  we can do something like that  by injection inside or almost a cleaning  because you see it gets on the lungs and  it does a tremendous number long so it'd  be interesting to check that so that  you're gonna have to use medical doctors  with but it sounds it sounds interesting  to me the new headline is trumpets  people to go outside that's dangerous  here we go same old group you ready I  hope people enjoy the Sun